I wanna focus on what many of you have said you would like me to elaborate on.
What can you do...
...about the climate crisis?
What can you do?
Reduce emissions in your home.
Most of these expenditures are also profitable.
Insulation, better design, buy green electricity where you can.
I mentioned automobiles: buy a hybrid.
Use light rail.
Figure out some of the other options that are much better.
It's important.
Be a green consumer.
You have choices with everything you buy,...
...between things that have a harsh effect...
...or a much less harsh effect on the global climate crisis.
Consider this.
Make a decision to live a carbon-neutral life.
Those of you who are good at branding,...
...I'd love to get your advice and help on how to say this...
...in a way that connects with the most people.
It is easier than you think.
It really is.